Jennifer Garner explains her and Ben  Affleck's new normal one step at a time  the couple announced their split over a  year ago but they've still never filed  for divorce here's what the nine live  star said on The Today Show Thursday  morning so as modern families go how's  your family doing we are definitely a  modern family we are we're doing really  well thank you you went to Europe  recently too good daily bonding trip you  know Ben was working in London on  Justice League and I felt like well the  kid should have that experience and he  and I are great friends and we just we  just all went in Mass that's really  admirable how you know you and Ben have  both it's all about children first and  and being a team and that actually  didn't have to do you don't have a  choice it has to be